so far there are just a few souvenirs on
display in the Osuna museum Game of
Thrones figures and some board games
Osuna is a small town in southern Spain
locals are hoping for an imminent
invasion of fans of the hit us TV show
vino vino vino la cabeza fuera we've
long been fans of Game of Thrones so we
were keen to see the original locations
I really feel it's a not us to go okay a
much ammonia we realized there are a lot
of sites worth seeing like a turtle
racer this bullfighting arena featured
in the fifth season 86,000 people
applied as extras and hundreds were
hired asos casino works with the local
council it found itself in undated with
inquiries even before the episodes
featuring Osuna were shown some tourists
aquella visto a that the source of
tourists who love Game of Thrones want
to see where it was shot vienen para
conocer el places like this bullfighting
arena for example or fire that nuckie
then they'll also take a look at what
else there is to see in town de sitio de
una que tiene mucho conciliar Osuna is a
textbook Andalusian town but it only
attracts some ten thousand tourists a
year that's not many like everywhere in
Spain it's been hard hit by the
country's economic crisis most locals
work in the agricultural sector many
grow olives and rosemary but
unemployment is rife one out of every
three is out of work no wonder they're
pinning their hopes on Hollywood
I'll I would have either Pueblo well
it's revitalizing the area yeah the
situation used to be desperate but it's
changing my daughter got a job as an
extra she played a slave and had a job
for 11 days hotels and restaurants are
hoping to see a rise of up to twenty
percent in the number of tourists
visiting the town Casa CUDA is a tapas
bar it's going all out to attract Game
of Thrones tourists some of its 200
dishes on the menu have even been named
after characters from the show too many
people order these special tapas they do
the Khaleesi salad is popular mucho esta
la lancelot hace mucho and the Lannister
and the Baratheon
this former stone quarry now hosts
readings and concerts it caught the eye
of the game of thrones location scouts
density our solo una scenario and we
ended up shooting and not just one but
at least two locations there so that
obviously makes the place even more
interesting for tourists quality of the
stone quarry will double as a dragon's
lair in season six of Game of Thrones by
the time it here is next year Osuna will
no doubt have become a major landmark on
Fantasy fans world map